The Hollywood Reporter called Disney's
chairman and CEO Bob Iger the most
powerful person in entertainment now in
his first book he's sharing the values
he embraced while reinventing the Walt
Disney Company it's called the ride of a
lifetime and in an eager outlines 10
principles he says are necessary for
true leadership since he became CEO in
2005 Disney has acquired Pixar Marvel
Lucasfilm and 21st Century Fox oh and by
the way the first Disney Resort opened
in mainland China it's a big one and the
subscription services ESPN plus and
Disney Plus were also unveiled that is a
live Bob Iger of good morning good
morning thank you for having me Disney
Plus is coming soon right in November
first it's number 12 November 12th is
gonna be available I got to ask from the
consumer point of view here there are a
lot of these subscription subscription
services now in fact Consumer Reports
added them up and if you have all the
top ones it actually cost more now than
a regular cable bill so as you enter
that fray is it getting to the point
where for you guys the win someone else
is gonna have to lose on that front well
first of all I think that there will be
room for consumers to buy more than one
subscription service and we'll see more
of that not only more than one but two
three we'll see in our case the Disney
Plus service as Disney Marvel Pixar Star
Wars and National Geographic so we enter
the market in a very very unique
position those brands those stories both
the library and the original product
that we're creating under those brand
umbrellas so while we believe we're
competing with others in reality there's
only one Disney with that collection
collection of assets diplomatically said
but a message is clear you guys think
you're gonna be the one people go to
well we're not short on confidence
listen we all know if everybody in the
room when you walk and we all know
you're a bad man and Jama Bob Iger but I
think it's important to go back to where
you started and I think it's very
interesting that you write when you were
coming up you had no definition of
success or leadership or wealth you just
knew based on your family environment
you talked about your dad who suffered
from depression that you just didn't
want to fail at what you were doing my
father had manic depression and because
of that he had a very hard time holding
jobs and I was well aware of that as a
child
growing up but what I was most aware of
is how disappointed he was in himself he
was well-educated he had big dreams for
himself particularly coming out of World
War two he was in the Navy in World War
two and he never fulfilled those dreams
so I watched him lead a life of
disappointment self disappointment and I
just did not want to have the same you
were determined not to be that and so
let's jump ahead here's Bob who's worked
at Disney who's worked in this company
for over 40 something years starting
from five years starting from low man at
the totem pole to where you are now but
you tell a great story in the book that
something happened with Roone Arledge
who I met once and I thought he was a
very scary dude I was very intimidated
by him but something had gone wrong and
somebody had to you had made a mistake
and when ruin says in the room who did
it you spoke up and you were
20-something at the time yes I was a
lower-level production program executive
and I had made a mistake and in a room
full of people where we were doing a
post-mortem on our weekend sports
coverage I owned up to that mistake and
I did so because it was the truth and I
just figured eventually you know people
would find out the truth where's that
expression the truth will set you free
and maybe I learned that early on but it
was extremely empowering to admit the
mistake people were so shocked that I
was actually made a mistake why was it
empowering didn't it mistake well I
lived to fight another day
I was never punished for it I fact I
think they were so respectful the fact
that I admitted it was me that they know
people lost sight of the fact that I had
that I had you had a dream of being
Walter Cronkite at one point I did it's
interesting being here yes I did yes I
grew up in 50s and 60s and watched
Walter you know cover many many
monumental stories of my life the space
program of course and the Kennedy
assassination Vietnam War and you you
may know that America look up looked up
to him you actually tagged along with
the CBS News team at 1:00 I did I have
this building when I was in college I
was assigned to a CBS News team to learn
a little bit more about the business and
I thought Walter was one of the most
respected individuals in the country at
the time and I wanted to be him and then
never quite made it I did not have the
confidence to pursue that career path I
didn't
was good enough yeah that's so
interesting that you didn't have the
confidence for that but you have the
confidence to do what you've done
well I've obviously over these years
I've built up a lot of confidence but
I've believed in myself in this you know
45 year path many times and it wasn't
filled with much self-doubt - you know
we've got to be optimistic because
nobody wants to be ruled by somebody
who's a pessimistic leader nobody nobody
wants that in their life that's
something that you do well working for
someone who's always telling you this
guy is falling or we're doing this but
it probably won't work oh my goodness
look what we're up against now that just
doesn't do anybody below that person any
good I think there has to be a sense of
the possible and always instilling that
sense that either something can be
overcome or can be achieved even against
long odds we're gonna take a break but
we're gonna ask Bob Iger to give us one
more piece of advice when we come back
can you stay for one more piece of
advice yes he can